thanks very much for the introduction
maybe as a disclaimer in advance um this
is about combined complexity stuff and
um uh bar touches the surface of
circuits but I guess regarding some
discussions on Wednesday I think it's
still still very interesting for
this okay so um I guess we all can agree
that like in the last couple of years
there has been significant progress in
Sol in gorial heart problems in practice
and one of the Frameworks um that one
could use there besides a
satisfiability programming or logic
programming where we model um Problems
by means of logical programs and
solutions to this programs are called
answer
sets uh in fact it's a quite generic
framework um used both in Academia and
Industry um so there are already two
universities spin offs uh one is from
University of colia one is from
University of poam uh in
Germany so what we can do there is like
model Comm Ro H problems like optimizing
shifting plans or assigning machines uh
products in different production phases
to machines such that the overall
production phase is
optimized
um uh we can also do like uh
certain
certain uh Logistics problems um like in
a classical Warehouse scenario where we
essentially have um Goods that we need
to bring from a warehouse to a
dispatching uh
system such that Um this can be done via
say robots that kind of Transport
shelves from one location to the other
such that they do not
Collide and we want to do this
efficiently uh we can also do train
scheduling and and so
so what do these problems have in common
well they can be modeled as aoral
problem um now the question is why and
like in which cases can we solve them
efficiently um well actually the answer
is not fully settled so um it's still
not clear like whether they I give you
when I give you a set instance or a
logic program and I ask you can this be
solved efficiently in general um what we
know though is that like the instance
structure might tell
and this is exactly what this
talk will be about so it's about
treewidth one of the
most cited commodor invariance so like
in general we know that problems on
graphs or like arbitrary structures are
quite hard um but if you look at the
special cases like B tree with then most
of problems become easy or many of them
become easy um and trith is usually
defined in terms of 3D compositions and
the 3D composition can then be used to
obtain so-called uh fpt results so we
are focusing on
algorithms uh that run uh in time Pol
normal and instance size but
Additionally the rantom also depends on
the value of a function depending only
on the parameter tree with K so in a
sense we want to restrict the hardness
or the commor explosion to this stre
with parameter
um which
is in contrast to the general case where
we cannot confine hardness right a
prior um so the question now is how do
these f ofk look like uh and if you have
specific F of K maybe can we do better
can we improve um so kind of as an
intuition these F of KS give you the so
typically the way these algorithms work
is like one dynamic programming on the
TR composition where we
essentially compute for each node a
table um and then in the end we need to
like modify these tables from the leaves
towards the root so it's a bottom up
computation and when we arrive at the
root of the decomposition node and there
is nonm table we know there is a
solution we can actually construct the
solutions so this F of K kind of gives
how hard or what we expect in terms of
uh run time for each of these tables
kind of the sub problem solving effort
and tri kind of gives you like the
largest sub problems that we encounter
kind of during these computations so how
do these functions look like and can we
do significantly better and then maybe
as a side question does this imply
consequences in practice or like
depending on different F of KS do we
still expect solvability in
practice so what I will show in the next
couple of minutes is um a decomposition
guided reduction which is uh
parameterized reduction that gets a 3D
composition for now we can just assume a
polymer time reduction and the purpose
of this reduction is given an instance
and the corresponding 3D composition
reduced to another problem such that we
immediately get a 3D composition of the
resulting instance so it's um kind of a
uh po time reduction if you want for
this talk where uh
the instance we construct by the
reduction has a tight relation to the 3D
composition we started from like a
functional dependen dependency with
these reductions we can show specific
rum upper bounds um for several
problems uh relevant to Ai and um
knowledge representation and reasoning
here we will mainly focus on specific F
ofk values for uh logic
programming uh we accompany this by
corresponding lower bounds under the
exponential time
hypothesis we brought a brief glimpse
into how one can show lower bonds for
problems harder than the PO hierarchy
and you want to use trith under the
exponential time hypothesis and finally
we still show how despite certain say
scary F ofk functions we can still
efficiently uh utilize dth to some
extent in practice
um so what we can do is we can do a
table right specific decision problems
we can also do counting problems there
nonclassical complexity results uh and
corresponding random dependency what
might be uh interesting here is like the
difference between tight ASP and normal
ASP these are specific fragments of
logic programming both are uh in
complete but the Tre dependency is
expected to be different under the
exponential time hypothesis so for
normal ASP we're expected to require
slightly more effort despite both have
same classic
complexity uh yeah and then there are
different extensions of logic
programming and harder form like harder
fragments um that give you larger D
dependency okay so back to dth I guess
most to be familiar now with trth since
this appeared already several times in
the course of this Workshop um so trth
kind of gives um a way to capture the
tree likeness of a given graph or
um uh essentially shows how
close set graph is to being a
tree um so what is a Tre de composition
or joint tree we also had this R several
times so 3D composition of a graph is
just an arrangement of the graph into a
tree where um each uh note of the tree
called back gets assigned vertices of
the graph such three properties all the
vertices of the graph for which we can
composition have to be
captured um by a tree so they have to
appear at least one back every Edge has
to be covered so two end points
of ver are covered uh every Edge has to
be covered so the two end points of each
Edge have to be get at least one back
and finally um connectedness is
important for us to design nice
algorithms on top so if you restrict a
tree to a certain vertex the result is
still
connected you can check here for all the
vertices most importantly the width of a
3D composition is the um largest back
size and find that the tree width is
kind of the best width we can hope for
um so like smallest width more potential
3D compositions in sense kind of tells
us if you want to use Tre with this is
kind of the largest sub problem size we
expect when
so uh any questions so far
what's the capacity of finding the
optimal um you can do this in uh it's in
hard but you can do this in think
exponential time theid there are like
two
approximations I think is Curr best one
in DEC
time um yeah you can also compute it
optimality to the k squ or something is
the latest result from this here
something yeah so but usually I mean if
you just interested in working with a 3D
composition you can use efficient
tics so what's the decomposition gr
reduction we have been given a 3D
composition of a graph representation of
an instance uh and we want to compute a
destination instance or an instance of
the target problem and the idea kind of
is that we use this
decomposition to construct the resulting
instance and then one can do a
functional dependency between Source
corresponding Source bag and the
destination back um so in the end we
immediately get the 3D composition as a
result which function depends on the
instance on the tree de composition of
the instance which allows you to
immediately show certain width increases
or
decreases um yes and this was exactly
the question that was already asked some
seconds ago thanks very much so we can
um uh theistically compute 3D
compositions um
um and we can also approximate then in
same okay so what how do we use these
decomposition gu reductions to show up
BS well the known reductions before from
ASP to set why do we want to you reduce
to set well for set we know that it can
be solved in think exponential time for
assuming if nothing is known want to
show this result right so the non
reductions before essentially didn't
take quite take care of the Tre so um
and one can show examples that all of
these reductions essentially massively
blow up the tree within the r case
saying instance size large so what we
want to do is we want to do a reduction
from ASP to S there just slightly
increasing the Tre
um so from K to k l k in
general before I going to do this let's
briefly previous IT anet
programming um so a logic program or an
answerers set program is a set of rules
which are essentially just implications
of this form uh where we say uh we have
a positive body and a negative body of
each rule and essentially this means
that whenever we set the positive body
to true all the atoms there and none of
the negative body then also the head has
to be set to
True um so this is the one thing the one
side of the semantics so we require
satisfiability uh in the sense of an
implication but in addition we require
something else we require that
everything we said to true or everything
that we have in our model is proven so
what does this mean require that exists
a rule for every such a with a in the
head such that all the positive body
atoms are in m and none of these
negative are
in um actually there's a little bit more
to it so we
should also exclude cyclic proofs
because the the idea of this formalism
is essentially that
um you require witness for everything
you derive or set to true so if you have
like a cyclic proof that just depends on
itself you again just don't have a
witness right you require everything you
derive um that you have a justification
for everything you
derive um and I think this is one of the
simplest formalizations of of
ASP um decision complexity is MP
complete since we can do that I mean
really as part uh of set
satisfiability um okay so how do we do
this now let's look at briefly an
example consider the program Pi where we
have
like uh not B so require a if we have
not B we require B if we have not a
require B if if a and c not C and
require C if if not
D there are two sets of this program one
would be AC and the other one would be
BC essentially this can be seen as kind
of a guess between our choice between A
and B this one is never applicable
because here we require that if D is set
to false and C is set to false so this
one is essentially IR relevant so
essentially we just have a guess between
a and b and we require to have C if you
do not have or in other words um all of
these are
Justified because a is justified by by
this rule C is justified by that rule uh
and in this case b is justified by this
Rule and C is
Justified so these are all the answer
sets um and in order to utilize Tre
withth what we need to do we need a
certain graph representation here let's
say um we
uh we satisfied with the Primal graph
where we have uh as where is the atoms
of the program and we place an edge
between two atoms whenever they
corresponding uh between two vertices
when the corresponding atoms appear
together in at least one rule so this
would be like a structural
representation of this program and now
in order to do
um a decomposition guid reduction we
need a 3D
composition um we can approximate it
efficiently uh and the goal would be to
kind
of guide our reduction along the 3D
composition from the bottoms to the
leaves in order to augment get a new 3D
composition where we have sort of
provability
of an atom up to a certain
node so essentially we have like a
linear blow up in the back size if you
compare pressor back to the accessor
back okay so how do we do this we guide
provability for atoms along the 3D
composition um what we can do is first
of all we check whether
um all the rules are satisfied this is
just the implication part so for each
rule using only atoms of a b we just uh
essentially write down the implication
as a logical formula then what we need
to do is we need to Define provability
of an atom up to not t which means
whenever there's a rule in a bag
containing X in the head then either we
have proability in this node which is if
there is in the rule we have all the
positive body atoms and none of the
negative body atoms or we have
provability already below a not in t um
and we do this for all the elements of
the bag and finally we just have to say
whenever we said something to true so
whenever we D something we require that
this proven in the end what do we mean
by in the end whenever uh we have a bag
with x uh in it where it doesn't occur
anymore um from there on so this is
actually all that's needed one can
easily um transform this into a proxim
monus reduction by replacing
implications here by
equivalences um so how does this look on
our example we take the program and
corresponding 3D composition we
construct the formula uh as specified
essentially just transforming the
implications into CNF which is trival
right defining provability of an atom up
to certain Noe and in the end enforcing
whenever we set uh an ATM to true then
we require that it's proven up to the
last not so here like in T2 a is
forgotten because here it appears for
the very last time so whenever said it
to requ probility of a up to
T2 and we almost immediately get a
corresponding 3D composition with nice
properties so here we see it's linear
and I promis something like K log K
right um the point is this was just for
tight programs because I didn't consider
Cycles so far what I mean by Cycles as
already mentioned we do not allow cyclic
dependencies positive cyclic
dependencies um for a proof so this
would be in that case
okay so um in order to address this
let's just assume uh such a program
where we have cyclic dependency among
the positive body atoms essentially we
cannot prove any of these positive body
any of these um atoms because
essentially we cannot start right the
proof of a require uh depend the proof
of B depends on the proof of a which
depends on proof of c and so on um so
it's uh this program only has an empty
answer Set uh as is solution so in order
to treat these cycles and this is
essentially what gives this blow up what
we need to do is we need to kind of
partially order um atoms so in each bag
we locally order the atoms and ensure
that this local ordering is essentially
consistent with neighboring Tre
composition noes so we require like log
K additional bits for each 3D
composition node and guide this
information on the 3D composition
um if one carries this uh carries this
carefully we obtain uh the mentioned
result um however the reduction is not
parsimonious because essentially we have
like a partial ordering and we we do not
know
global global position in this in this
ordering so uh the current suspicion is
that counting normal answer sets for
normal programs should is expected to be
harder uh than the
problem uh however there is no formal
proof for it so be happy if somebody
would be interested in
that um so we also did some practical
experiments uh we implemented reasoning
over logical programs uh we also
considered the
proog
um say formalism uh and interestingly
what we compared we compared just like
the regular way of encoding provability
with provability guided along a 3D
composition and these n versions are the
vanilla versions without using Tre with
or 3D composition and the other variants
are essentially
extensions uh where we use different
variants of these decomposition gu
reductions so it seems that even these U
knowledge compilers in our settings
seems uh benefit from the information of
the 3D
composition so this is just as a take
out takea away from this slide
um yeah so with this we can also do some
other special fragments uh where we
essentially kind of bound
um say the cyclic dependency of um
positive Cycles in the dependency graph
of
program so the question now is like can
we significantly improve or can we do
better than in time due to the K log K
times Po in n and so like can we solve
uh significantly better in time
significantly better and the answer is
unfortunately we can't or at least it's
very unlikely um so this brings us to
decomposition gr reductions for using
lower
bonds um so what's known is that like
the cyclic dependencies are kind of the
reason for hardness uh of logic programs
so there is a known result so if you do
not use um additional oxil variables you
cannot translate normally SP to S
without an exponential blow up however
this really uses um prohibits auxiliary
variables so for tri Tex is slightly
different um so the underlying reason
for hardness in a sense is that we do
not see this positive Cycles in the
worst case so it's like they might be
completely spread across the whole 3D
composition it's similar to like
following a magnifier glass along a very
large cycle or many cycles so we do not
see the cyclic information
uh all at
once so this kind of prevents an
algorithm uh from analyzing the psychic
dependencies um and one can show
hardness or the to the K Lo lower Bound
by reducing for BL called disjoint paths
where we have we want to find vertx
disjoint path between Pairs of source
and destination vertices uh and the idea
is that well we know bound from this
case so cannot do better than with f of
K to the K okay and the challenge now is
to reduce from this joint path problem
with just a linear trith increase and
again we can use a decomposition guided
reduction for that and ensure that the
trith increase or the width increase is
actually just linear uh and the idea is
there to do reachability with um
reachability vertices but not for each
pair because this would already blow up
the withd probably uh to guide along the
decomposition whether you already have
chosen for a specific vertex uh an edge
an outgoing
Edge and in the end we need to link
those pairs to get in a certain order
since the order is not clear in advance
um we also do this along the 3y
composition because there we know that
this order that has been captured in the
Tre composition doesn't blow up the tree
width so with that we uh obtain the
corresponding lower bound
um and another the question would be can
we maybe generalize this technique or
can we use decomposition guide
reductions as kind of a tool to show
lower bonds for higher level problems um
since ni and KR they appear naturally
there uh
and the obvious candidate or one obvious
candidate is deciding the validity of a
Quantified bullan formula because there
we know an algorithm which runs in Alpha
exponential time in the tree width with
on the top so it's 2
22 height L on the top
um and what we showed is that you cannot
significantly improve that on
exponential time and the proof goes by a
decomposition gu reduction from
Quantified po deciding valid of
Quantified poan form with L quantifi
blocks to increasing the quantify block
by one plus this
um increase of quantify block allows you
to significantly compress the trid so we
can compress the Tre from K to lock k at
the cost of an additional quantify block
and the reductions that have been done
so far before were like reducing from
threet using eth so under you cannot
expect or eth implies that you cannot
solve threet in time better than single
exponential in the number of variables
the previous uh attempts were reducing
from three set to like say Q2 but the
new withth is like logarithmic in the
number of variables of the instance Serv
from this approach is slightly different
we Ru from K from 3 with K to Q2 with
with log K so we have like a relation
here and why is this more
beneficial well I would just say it's
simpler because with the same technique
with the same idea we can just reduce
from Q L to Q l+ one and the essentially
doing the same reduction whereas I have
honestly no idea how to reduce 3 set
with K from to Q set 3 so three quantif
blocks and making log log in this idea
essentially doesn't easily generalize to
that one so the advant here is that we
can actually do induction over it and
obtain a lower Bound
for all the
cases so maybe as a so I did a weird
figure
just to show
um maybe as a disclaimer this is kind of
a simplified illustration of uh how how
the reduction goes and essentially the
idea is as follows uh we start with the
3D composition um with log K trith you
cannot in a bag refer to more than
one element of the original
B so we use concept of pointer where we
just refer to one element of the
original bag um and in the end these
pointers allow us to kind of make a new
reduction that gets rid of connectedness
of the trid so we whenever we introduce
a certain um vertex of the graph so we
haven't seen it so far in the 3D
composition we make a new copy so we
have all these
copies and so essentially we don't have
connectedness anymore right and we Al we
can make sure that there is only like a
constant number of introduces in each 3D
composition node so these are like
constantly
many and then with these pointers and
the additional quantifier block we kind
of repair connectedness again so it's
like first of all we destroy the Tre
decomposition property so um getting rid
of connectedness adding copies and then
using this additional quantifier block
we allow to we enable to synchronize
these copies such as that in the end the
copies
are uh in line as
before uh so it consists of three parts
um the guest part is something the thing
that happens uh when we introduce the
variable propagate part happens between
neighboring bags ensuring basically that
we repair connectedness and the check
Parts ensure that we can actually check
corresponding Clauses or three uh CNF
Clauses okay um if we still have time I
can show a brief example which actually
doesn't use Clauses but terms so we have
like exists for all qbf
with these
fours um as before we can do a uh Primal
graph
representation um so this would be a
primal graph in order to make it simpler
we can construct a 3D composition say
again via
um uh the two approximation and we
constructed 3D composition where we only
have like one we only see one term in
each node uh this is just makes it
simpler uh and then the the resulting
reduction kind of looks like this so we
have these copies if you compare one
block from our source instance and we
have these copies for the universal ones
of course when we do copies we need to
shift it to the next existential block
because in the end we want to ensure
that these copies have the same value
right so you cannot just universally
quantify both copy
um we have the bit variables to ensure
that these pointers are in line right so
that we prepare connectedness and a
pointer also has values so it's like you
can point to a certain element of the
original pag and the Target also has a
specific value right true or false um so
how does this look like like the guess
part it's quite simple actually so so
whenever wt1 is true and we point to W
in T1 then also the value of T1
the point for1 has to be true same thing
for the for the false case and same
thing for the other copies so this is
actually quite
simple uh the propagate part is not much
harder essentially ensuring for
neighboring 3D composition uh bags that
we can synchronize those so whenever the
value in T4 is set to true and we point
to W in T4 and we also point to W in T3
then also the value for3 has to be sub
same same thing for the negative case
right
the check Port is a bit more involved
for checking a 3DF you need three
pointers for each of the terms right or
for each of the elements of the term um
and we also need to slightly up
propagation
there uh and we also need to pass the
information of whether we already
satisfied this formula along the 3D
composition um which is just constant
overhead um
yeah so in the end it looks something
like this basically this thing just cop
it three times uh and some satisfiable
information um in the end we can show
that like the tree withth is uh
logarithmic so we need something like 12
log plus
13 um this is just because of
technicalities I guess um would be
interesting on whether we can do
significantly better there just get rid
of this um just use three times whatever
it's because of the synchronization
between neighboring bags um yeah
just blow up in the Lo in the log uh in
the end we can show the lower Bond but
just using induction just use the
reduction from s uh just apply it as
long as you need to get
the quite simple um it also works for
planer structures so like C planer said
um one can show with this decomposition
guide reductions by using just very
restricted decompositions that it also
works for bandwidth and cutwidth
parameters recently we extend is to
feedback vertic size and tree depth but
for the incidence graph there is a
small say maybe not so nice thing for
the Primal graph we require really long
Clause um when we generalize this
technique so it would be also
interesting to fix this missing case for
the Primal graph
um uh any questions so
far so the nice thing now is that we can
just use the result right so instead of
reducing from three set fork and R
making showing a lower Bound for a
problem that's expected to be slightly
higher uh in this F ofk say two or three
fold we don't need to make uh a new
parameter that's like log log log or
something in end but we can just reduce
from qile to have a problem um yeah of
course depending on what the this
reduction does it might change uh the
tree with but um you don't need to
overcome exponential barriers so to say
all the
time um we can do this for different
problems in uh Ai and KR classify
according to hardness for tree with
maybe to give a bit of like a summary
here um so just to kind of visualize
decomposition qu reductions so if you
take the Tre withd on the x-axis or
largest sub problem size and like
largest sub problem size here kind of
and like sub problem solving effort or F
of K on the y-axis then what these
decomposition guide reductions allow is
to kind of go from one spot here um so
kind of decrease the sub problem solving
effort at a cost of an increase in
larger sub size and the other way around
which pred for three withd so go to
harder fragment that has like smaller
like from to as we've seen for the qbf
reduction um still have some minutes or
don't
I um then maybe to like summarize this
or to ask the question of what do we do
with these classification results can we
still utilize them in practice um the
thing is we can use Tri with but what we
observed is that kind of an ract version
of TR with would be would be ideal so
pick a subset of uh uh the vertices of
your graph and take the induced subg
graph and then uh we add additional
edges to this graph namely whenever
vertices in the set are connected to the
same connected component of the graph of
the induced subc without s so this kind
of ensures that we see larger sub
problems later in one bag of the 3D
composition of the resulting graph so in
other words what we're doing is we're
doing
like um the simplified graph
representation where we uh can easily do
dynamic programming along but each bag
is large so we have like larger sub
problems in each bag but we do not use
dynamic programming on these larger
instances but we use say a sub solver
say any other existing solver and we
call this concept nested dynamic
programming since you can actually apply
this decomposition abstra abstraction
phase decomposition phase in a nested
way uh and then use other solvers maybe
circuits uh actually knowledge compilers
um for these large sub problems
say and this is a system called Nest hgp
which works quite well for
counting so um what we did is we tested
a series of uh counting instances so
counting the numbers of uh assignments
of formula and projected counting which
is expected to be double exponential in
the
truth uh we did I would say
reasonable uh limits uh on the wall
clock time and uh main memory and um to
show some results what's quite
interesting here is that um we use sharp
S as a Subs solver so these are called
Cactus plots maybe just don't go into
details here but like being lower and
more towards the right is bad solves
more instances faster so we use this one
as a as a Subs solver uh in order to
arrive kind of here um so it's kind of a
hybrid treewidth based solver by
combining ideas from fress complexity
and uh uh other techniques from model
County uh what's quite interesting is
that the width of we work withth are
really large like to 200 something um
just because like we do not materialize
Solutions and we just have like a
combination of classical cdcl based uh
techniques with truth based approaches
and it also works for projected
counting
um there we also have like a there we
have a benefit if we parallelize so this
is like the paralyzed version this is a
single core version uh we see it's kind
of competitive right it's
of more effort I guess also because of
computing the abstractions and stuff but
it's kind of competitive with what has
been up there and the interesting part
is like we still use kind of large
decompositions for being up menion this
works for many other Frameworks and
extensions it's kind of a generalized
principle and just to note there are
also other hybrid approaches available
um so to conclude we have seen the
composition guide reductions the
application for upper and lower bounds
we show that ASP might be actually
harder than S if you believe in the
exponential time hypothesis at least
provided kind of an idea on a low bound
methodology based on Quantified poolan
formulas um currently focusing on non
ASP uh yeah there is the
interesting circumstance that um you can
actually simplify queries kind of um
just because the formalism is already
quite high on it's on second layer of Po
hierarchy which allows you to simplify
queries such that can
essentially um we do not need to
evaluate a whole body of a rule in in as
as once but we can actually split split
the
bodies
um what's still open is uh the result
for sharps spe the low Bond I still
expect that it's double exponential to
be honest and I can give some arguments
about that
uh one can still think about lower
bounds for other parameters and me
actual the concept is quite General
right um and it would be quite nice to
have theoretical models for using hu
withth in practice because
obviously H withth might not be too bad
in practice just depends on how you use
it and how the specific 3D composition
looks like thanks very much for
attention
[Applause]
you have one
question I think it was in the table
that you show with the complexity the
also the disjunctive fragment of
ASP does disjunction had any complexity
can you do the same things if you have
disjunction in in the heads what do you
mean the same things theun Jun facep is
harder right I mean your reductions with
the bound the three Reef would they work
if you have this
Junctions yeah why why wouldn't it work
I don't know I'm asking that uh it's
it's it's it's really just a general
principle you just do the reduction
guided along the lines of the of the 3D
composition and in fact you can do a
reduction from 2 qbf to disjunctive ASP
but they take care that you do not mess
up the truth in the process right so
it's really kind of a
generic principle I would
say yeah thanks for the
question right thanks Mar again
thanks so